depuis le divorce de ses parents et le
départ de son père Jean-Claude est le
seul à rapporter chaque mois un peu
d'argent à la maison et pour sa mère
c'est un peu lui le chef de
[Musique]
famille il s'appelle Jean-Claude il a 16
ans et demi il habite à maison alfort
dans la banlieue de
Paris
[Musique]
19h45 Jean-Claude arrive place de la
République il est chasseur de nuit dans
un grand
hôtel à 16 ans Jean-Claude a quitté le
collège technique où il étudiait le le
dessin industriel pour gagner sa vie
tout de suite il a été groom dans un
autre hôtel puis
télégraphiste comme beaucoup de jeunes
Français Jean-Claude fait ses premiers
pas dans le monde du travail sans
formation professionnelle
8h du soir cette longue nuit qui
commence c'est la moitié de la vie de
Jean-Claude il ne quittera plus l'hôtel
pendant 12h jusqu'à 8h du matin il n'a
qu'une nuit de congé par
[Musique]
semaine
all
comment je comprends
rien
ce personnage qui ne se laisse jamais
déborder par l'affluence des clients qui
répond dans toutes les langues à toutes
les questions c'est le concierge c'est
l'homme au clé
d'or à l'âge de Jean-Claude d'autres
rêvent de devenir médecin ingénieur
technicien même s'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité d'y parvenir Jean-Claude lui
ne rêve pas il a pesé le pour et le
contre décidé une fois pour toutes il
sera concierge d'hôtel concierge on a un
métier tranquille c'est pas fatiguant et
c'est bien c'est bien
çaesse sa tranquillité ouais on est
tranquille on a son petit travail on
n'est pas on n'est pas disputé par
quelqu'un on n pas de patron mais mais
si nous le patron par exemple de la loge
on se trouve dans un genre de petite
loge si nous Pons de la loge il y a
personne qui est qui est dans nos pieds
c'est
bien concierge de Grand Hôtel un métier
tranquille des pourboir fabuleux c'est
sans doute le rêve de la plupart des
Groms et des
chasseurs encore faut-il pour y parvenir
être capable d'apprendre en quelques
années deux ou tris langues et l'art de
répondre au désirs les plus divers d'une
clientèle
exigeante
est-ce que ça vous plaît oui
merci en attendant Jean-Claude doit se
contenter des petites servitudes du
métier et de leur petit profit il
gagnent environ 800 francs par mois 12
francs avec les pourbois and on
accompagne un client dans sa chambre
avec les valises il y a de valises assez
lourdes mon truc alors au lieu de
prendre un chariot parce qu'on a le
droit de prendre un chariot on porte à
la main on fait mon trour qu'on se
fatigue un peu des fois le pourbire est
un peu plus gr
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
[Musique]
merci minuit le concierge et les
chasseurs veillent seul sur l'hôtel les
clients se font rares et pour boire
aussi tu te vois pas dans une usine par
exemple oh non oh non le bruit tout non
le bruit seulement non il y a pas que le
bruit on est beaucoup il faut faire son
travail soit on est à la chaîne
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
faut travailler au rendement il y a
certain usine al il faut dépêcher faut
que ça soit
bien le travail est fait c'est
[Applaudissements]
principal
2h3 comme chaque nuit Jean-Claude
commence sa ronde son inspection des
portes closes et des couloirs vides
comme chaque nuit il sait d'avance qu'il
n'y aura rien à
signaler
[Musique]
3h du matin Jean-Claude va enfin se
faire remplacer il a droit maintenant à
3h30 de
sommeil
allez encore ouais ah
il y a il y a les mecs en par
françaisessay de te débrouiller parce
que je comprends
rien
bon la porte
8h du matin le travail reprend pour les
autres il vient de chev pour Jean-Claude
avec les premiers clients du matin les
derniers pour boire de la
[Musique]
nuit видите
что
de l'hôtel où ils travaillent ensemble à
maison alfort où ils vivent tous les
deux de jour comme de nuit Jean-Claude
et Daniel sont inséparables ils ne se
quitent que pour aller
[Applaudissements]
dormir
aman complice
9h du matin les frères et les sœurs de
Jean-Claude sont à l'école même si la
maison est silencieuse Jean-Claude ne se
sent vraiment chez lui que lorsqu'il
s'est réfugié dans sa chambre entre sa
famille et lui il y a toujours cette
porte fermée pourtant depuis le divorce
de ses parents et le départ de son père
Jean-Claude est le seul à rapporter
chaque mois un peu d'argent à la maison
et pour sa mère c'est un peu lui le chef
de famille un étrange chef de famille de
16 ans et demi qui semble de passage
dans sa propre
maison
[Musique]
j' vrais manger sur
C tu es pas trop fatigué
[Musique]
non
ça t'a manqué de ne pas avoir de père au
début parce que mon père il avait quand
même
l'autorité c'était c'était
mieux manger à telle heure chaque jour
il fallait que ça soit pr il fallait
qu'on soit
là
maintenant tu crois que c'est bien pour
un enfant d'avoir eu cette vie là
d'avoir été obligé de se débrouiller
très jeune oui parce que il affronte
mieux la vie pour affronter la la vie
je trouve que je suis assez débrouillé
par rapport à un jeune s par commander
jusqu'à 18 ans après quient dans la vie
sait pas quoi faire sa pas comment se
débrouiller je trouve que c'est mieux ta
mère essae de parler avec toi oui elle
ESS mais sa pas qu'elle est agçante mais
si je commence
elle elle est tout le temps là je
préfère ne pas du tout parler ça
t'intéresse pas ce qu'elle te dit si il
y a des choses qui m'intéressent mais je
préfère parler avec mes camarades ils
viennent ici on discute fa ce qu'on veut
elle a combien d'enfants en tout avec
moi ou sans moi avec toi neuf neuf oui
c'est assez nombreux tu lui donnes un
coup de main par exemple tu lui donnes
une partie de ta paye ordinairement sur
ma paye il compter 600 francs mais si si
ça allait bien j'avais rien à acheter
600 francs par moi 60000 anciens francs
ouais
non moiême je pour donner moins parce
que tout ce que je donne il çaut pas le
prix mais pour ce que je fais pour ce
que je mange tout ça il y en a pour
moins cher il a peut-être pour 300
francs de nourriture par mois et s Fran
de logement
mettant c'est pour ça je préfère donner
plus parce que il y a mes Fran j'ai une
certaine responsabilité quand mêmeas
envie de te marier un jour oui je pense
bienimporte comment on se on se Mar
toujours un
jour qu'est-ce que tu demanderas à ta
femme comment demander je sais pas
comment tu l' comment tu voudrais
qu'elle soit ta femme jeune mais qu'elle
mon caractère c'est possible qu'on
s'entende bien qu'elle soit
fidèle qu'elle s'occupe bien de la
maison qu'elle soit jolie ça compte pas
si quand même je préfère avoir une femme
qui est quand même
joli ça c'est pas ce que tu m'as dit
d'abord c'est pas le plus important dans
un sens non ça on peut pas savoir ça ça
vient un jour tu es attrapé tu
attrapé qu'elle soit jolie ou pas
elle peut être jolie mais comme
moche ça c'est pas à toi de décider
hein tu jamais arrivé encore d'être
attrapé comme tu dis non vraiment
attraper
non non ça je suis jeune alors c'est
pasager mais tout ce qui se passe c'est
plus tard que ça
viendra aim bien la liberté ça va être
Durre rrapé ah oui assz parce que il
faudrait que je sois souvent pr de ma
femme j'aime pas être dans une maison
re je préfère toujoursre
[Musique]
de
tu passes combien de temps sur ta moto
dans la journée il faut compter 3 4 heur
par jour un peu la liberté la mot
oui mais c'est même beaucoup la liberté
ouais chaque fois qu'on peut sortir de
la ville mais c'est en
moto ça changé beaucoup de choses
d'avoir une moto dans ta vie assez oui
depuis que j'ai la moto je fais beaucoup
de choses que je faisais pas avant ou
par exemple aller au travail
avec aller me promener je on peut aller
se promener 50 km d'ici
on n pas besoin de de
transport tout de suite on prend la
mobyette et les copains par exemple si
on rencontre un autre gars à moto qu'on
connait pas
entre de moto on se fait toujours un
signe de la main Amal quoi la première
question qu'on pose c'est sur la moto
parce
que c'est tout ce qu'on a àoser nimporte
comment et là ça y est la glace est
remplu on est comm ah ou ou tout de
suite on on sympathise dès qu'on voit un
autre gar en moto on fait connaissance
et on est
[Musique]
sympathisé
touche
qu'est-ce que tu lis par exemple
çaarrive de lire oui les illustrés
surtout les illustr des BL des choses
comme ça des
mon des fantômes autrement les romans
j'aimerais ça mais si ça serait
l'IST autrement dire un roman juste la
lecture ça me plaît pas tellement
pourquoi ça te plaît pas parce que il y
a pas d'image il a rien juste de la
lecture qu'est-ce que ça t'apporte de
plus les
images je trouve c'est mieux et tu vois
com ça se passe tout les les scènes
c'est comme si après peut-être un mois
après moi moi il y a des que j'ai lu je
crois les avoir vu au
cinéma je me rappelle très bien quand
comment ça s'est passé la lecture avoir
vu les
je suis sûr de l'avoir vu au cinéma
pourtant je l'ai
vu ça devait pas intéresser de devenir
étudiant
non étudiant non ça me
pas bon
pourquoi l'école reprendre l'école tout
ça les devoir le soir apprendre les
leçons c'est pas mon genre ne pas être
payé aussi ne pas être payé aussi et
avoir quoi les maettes d'école qu'est-ce
qu' gagne Mo
nous il gagne moins qu'un chasseur et il
il a perdu du temps il a fallu avoir son
bac tout ça et je à mon
avis ça leur a servi à rien autant qu'il
passasse un métier manuel tu les trouves
sympathiques les étudiants
oui ils sont assez
sympathiques tu les trouves très
différents des des jeunes comme toi
oui par exemple il sont déjà moins libre
que nous il gag ils gagnent pas leur vie
ils travaillent pas ils vont à
l'école je trouve c'est pas pareil du
tout sont un peu comme des enfants pour
toi
oui comme comme dans les classes
primaires alors je préfère travailler me
débrouiller tout seul il y a des ratures
desur regarde-moi ça bonjour Ma fille
bonjour Maman bonjour Ma fille B les
enfants oup de devoir aujOurd'huii la
maesse elle m'a donné des devoirs il
faut que je les fasse pour
demain une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grosse
B aussi temp onim pas
tellement pour qu'on sait dansé
aussi c'est pour faire banqu alors ça
pas coup peut apprendre à danser bien s
on peutendre ça PL pas tellement la
dan et rencontrer des filles ça vous
intéresse pas
s et où vous V les rencontrer
alors on
peut tuas une petite amie en ce moment
Jean-Claude si je veux oui mais ça me
dit rien je préfère être libre faire ce
que je veux on est pris on doit aller la
voir tout
ça al des fois et tu vas pas me prendre
raison sacri tout ça je préfère on ne
pas en avoir
comment tu ferais si en avais une pour
te promener avec elle là je pourrais pas
parce que mon engin il est pas
immatriculé mais j'espère avir mais
quand j'aurai ma moto vers la fin du
mois d'octobre quand tu auras ta moto tu
auras une petite amie peut-être j'espère
ouais comme ça c'est vra je pourrais
l'emmener mais j'aurais le droit tout
c'est plus intéressant quoi parce que
laisser dans un coin puis se ramener à
pied c'est pas pas tellement marrant
quoi même avec une jolie fille même même
une B a une moto on va partout on
l'emmène où on veut c'est plus F
femme ça toujs
nous vendredi 21h c'est le soir de Cong
de
jeanclude le grand rendez-vous
hebdomadaire des jeunes fanatiques de la
moto pendant quelques heures on va se
sentir entre soi ici au moins on est sûr
de trouver un peu de chaleur un peu de
fraternité
[Musique]
peut-être un jeune homme raisonnable à
16 ans et demi comme on peut l'être à 40
ou 50 ans un jeune homme sans idéal
comme on dit tel est Jean-Claude une
seule passion dans sa vie la moto ça va
ti ça va je sais pas ce qu'il a mais
pas mais
[Musique]
la elles sont elles sont détériorées
C tu VO non celu ça va être plus dur tu
vois il y a le il y a la partie du
cratère qui est rester dans la dans la V
platinée dans le contact je contact
vas-y
oui bien une plate bien plate comme ça
là tu comme ça
vas-y voir encore un peu encore un pe
[Musique]
oui ou ça va aller
là aucune de nos questions n'a pu
troubler Jean-Claude à 16 ans et demi il
a déjà choisi ce qu'il sera et ce qu'il
ne sera pas il croit du moins avoir
librement choisi mais les circonstances
de sa vie lui ont-ell enseigné autre
chose que cette maxime qui lui tient
lieu d'idéal pour s'en sortir il faut se
débrouiller seul et parmi ceux qu'il
côtoi qui pourrait lui laisser entrevoir
d'autres
solutions
[Musique]